[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau 7,8 le débat le français aime
parler de politique ils le font chez eux
entre amis et bien sûr sur leur lieu de
travail mais une grande majorité d'entre
nous considèrent qu'il n'est pas correct
de défendre un candidat devant des
collègues pour tenter de les convaincre
alors oui au débat d'idées non
prosélytisme pour autant n'est-il pas
risqué d'afficher ses opinions au
travail quelle frontière avec
l'engagement syndical
enfin que penser du cas de l'entreprise
paprec avec mon pour en parler
nicolas sans sel vous êtes avocat au
barreau de bars de versailles pardon
sonia pour vous êtes secrétaire général
de la cgt des yvelines bonsoir à tous
les deux nicolas sont faits elle alors
peut-on étaler ses opinions politiques
au travail que tu la loi à ce sujet
alors les étals et pas forcément tout
est question de limites et
d'appréciation on ne sait que
notre constitution et la déclaration des
droits de l'homme réserve une garantie à
la liberté d'expression c'est un
principe fondamental de notre république
et notre démocratie dans l'entreprise
est la vocation est bien évidemment à
s'appliquer
la seule limite je dirais c'est l'abus
c'est à dire que à quel moment cela va
dégénérer
cette liberté d'expression va se
transformer bien ce que vous aviez
indiqué en prosélytisme en sujets qui
font polémique qui vont peut-être créer
un trouble au sein de l'entreprise c'est
là la limite qui va être apprécié
éventuellement si les dossiers sont
renvoyées devant des juridictions au cas
par cas
c'est vraiment du cas d'espèce où à
chaque fois la juridiction conseil des
prud'hommes pour ce qui est de sa
compétence va s'assurer que la sanction
prononcée à l'encontre du salarié est
adaptée à la situation
on sur cette question là on va pas
reprocher la même chose
ah je dirais un salarié qui seraient
éventuellement en bas d'une échelle de
hiérarchie avec quelqu'un qui peut être
cadres dirigeants et prendre des
positions politiques qui voulaient se
désintéressant palema exactement leur a
tout de suite après sonia porot là
dessus oui c'est vraiment fondamental de
défendre les libertés individuelles et
collectives dans l'entreprise
comme l'a dit m sont faits les libertés
ne s'arrête pas aux parts de
l'entreprise elles ont besoin d'être
protégés car les entreprises sont
justement un lieu de subordination et
qu'il faut du coup garantir les droits
des salariés
et puis les l'entreprise c'est un lieu
social collectif où le débat est aussi
formateur permet les différences permet
de faire évoluer les gens donc c'est
important qu'on puisse permettre le
débat effectivement dans les limites du
droit c'est à dire tout ce qui peut être
un jure discrimination incitation à la
haine ça effectivement c'est autre chose
ça tombe sous le coup de la loi mais
dans le fait est ce que l'expression est
vraiment libre aujourd'hui finalement
est-ce qu'on accepterait un collègue qui
nous parlerait de son engagement à
l'extrême gauche ou à l'extrême droite
est ce que finalement il va pas être un
peu isolé vraiment concrètement dans les
faits au quotidien dans la vie de
l'entreprise gère la réflexion elle est
plus social sur notre capacité à vivre
en société et faire société à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise ça tient
plus ça relève plus du droit
la seule limite vraiment qui est posée
par le droit et et code du travail
aujourd'hui
c'est dire que dans l'entreprise vous
êtes souvenir un lien de subordination
chef d'entreprise est propriétaire de
son outil et seul un tube ali nation
s'exprime et l'entreprise a le droit
d'apporter des limites mais seulement
qu'elle peut apporter c'est ce que le
code du travail savant qu'il doit être
justifiées par la nature de la tâche à
accomplir et proportionnées au but
recherché c'est la seule possibilité
d'apporter des limites à des libertés
protéger est ce qu'on risque pas d'être
discriminées par exemple je vais
travailler avec quelqu'un qui a des
convictions très opposées aux miennes
est ce que cette sont des litiges
auxquels vous avez à faire
moi je suis syndicaliste un militant
syndical donc évidemment où l'engagement
qu'on comporte et les libertés sont
celles liées à l'engagement syndical je
peux pas me prononcer pour ceux qui ont
des des engagements politiques mais en
général dans le monde du travail
quand le collectif de travail fonctionne
fonctionne bien qui a pas
mauvaise ambiance où des problèmes de
harcèlement qui va qui effectivement la
vienne perturber les relations de
travail les choses entre collègues dans
l'ensemble s'autorégule même quand il ya
des opinions relativement affirmé sur
sur des sujets la communauté de travail
souvent elle prime et en général il n'y
a pas de gros conflits
même quand il ya des désaccords ou des
positions différentes pas besoin d'aller
vers une poursuite judiciaire ça se se
résout au sein même de l'entreprise un
finalement oui les cas de conflits alias
à son façon extrêmement rare par contre
des discriminations syndicales ça c'est
un motif de discrimination et et on
défend très fermement les libertés
syndicales mais aussi toutes les
discriminations qui peuvent être liés au
sexe à l'orientation sexuelle ou à
l'origine ça ça à aigle et part handicap
aussi ça existe et ça doit être ça ça
doit être combattue alors justement par
rapport au syndicalisme mettre son fils
en préparant les missions vous me disiez
on n'a pas le droit de tracteurs
à certains endroits de l'entreprise donc
parce que c'est un engagement politique
le syndicalisme book quelle est la
frontière et du mal à vous suivre sur le
syndicalisme engagement politique
on sait d'ailleurs dans la tradition
française qu'on a bien une distinction
sans refaire l'histoire des syndicats
entre l'engagement syndical et
l'engagement politique quand toujours
été traité par tous les syndicats
français de façon très distincts contrat
mais peut-être à d'autres pays où ces
traités de façon différente donc il faut
pas confondre des deux est l'expression
syndicale est protégée en entreprise est
là pour le coup vous avez des
protections type anti discrimination les
entraves qui peuvent être portées à
l'encontre de représentants du personnel
syndicaux élus et représentants du
personnel sont là vraiment encadrer
sévèrement la liberté de l'employeur de
mettre des bâtons dans les roues à
l'expression syndicale
on est sur autre chose quand on parle
d'expression politique ça se rapproche
quasiment de l'expression religieuse en
entreprise qui est un événement est
évidemment intéressant dans ce débat le
syndicat et est protégé sans doute les
outils existent sans doute c'est
difficile à protéger madame à raison
pour en avoir été le témoin j'ai bien
évidemment pu constater l'existence de
discriminations en entreprise ils ont un
travail syndical de terrain des
syndicalistes ou syndiqués sur sur place
dans l'entreprise vraiment sur deux
choses différentes et vous avez pour en
terminer sur ce point là une distinction
à faire entre la liberté d'expression
qui est cette liberté d'exprimer toutes
ses opinions avec cette seule capacité à
mettre un terme aux obstacles qui est
l'abus et vous avez le droit
d'expression qui est un droit encadré
par le code du travail spécifiquement
les salariés monti du code du travail de
tant de temps
des outils pour exprimer éventuellement
une critique ou à faire progresser leur
entreprise et la cedh entendu travail
syndicats légalement et d'entendre sont
deux choses différentes
je suis très différents le syndicalisme
s'exprime sur des sujets politiques on
peut prendre position sur le programme
d'un candidat sur des mesures qu'un
gouvernement qu'une collectivité peut
mettre en place par rapport à ce qu'on
représente c'est à dire les salariés les
retraités les chômeurs et précaires
mais voilà on a effectivement distincts
et c'est vraiment important que
l'entreprise soit un lieu de débat on
n'a pas du tout envie de revenir
voilà au règlement des entreprises du
19e siècle c'était interdit de parler à
son voisin d'ateliers et les entreprises
souvent effectué celle de freiner cette
expression des salariés on se souvient
sur les chaînes automobile le fait de
mettre des salariés qui parlent pas la
même langue les uns à côté des autres
pour empêcher ce dialogue ça ça nous
paraît extrêmement extrêmement néfaste
les salariés sont bien de s'exprimer sur
leur travail de pouvoir parler de
l'intérieur on y passe est normal de ce
qu'ils vivent aussi en dehors du travail
parce qu'on s'intéresse à la vie des
salariés dans l'ensemble donc ça peut
être les conditions de transport de
logement comme on peut se soigner toutes
ces questions là l intérêt qu elle
intéresse le syndicalisme et on a besoin
d espace pour pour en parler et il faut
vraiment pas que ça se restreignent
parce que ça ça va être beaucoup plus
dangereux que
que ce qu'on croit alors justement on
parle de salariés via le cas des
dirigeants d'entreprise vous l'avez lu
que tout à l'heure que pensez-vous du
cas de l'entreprise pape règle le
dirigeant s'est clairement prononcé il a
alerté sur la menace d'une éventuelle
élection de marine le pen ar - là dessus
là j'ai plus de mal également en termes
de droits après tout c'est sa liberté
d'expression la plus totale et il
s'engage pas comme salarié la difficulté
du salarié avec ses attentes
l'entreprise placée en termes d'image
dresser les actionnaires ceux qui
détiennent entreprises qui pourraient
éventuellement se poser la question d'un
système je trouve ça légitime me semble
d'une prise de position sur sur la place
publique de notre entreprise dans un
débat après dès que je renvoie s'avère
le nôtre débats de société
sinon l'expression a été publique il
s'est quand même adressé aux milliers de
salariés de son entreprise avec avec sa
position de dirigeant et d'employeurs
même si en l'occurrence à la cgt
effectivement on pense que ce que porte
le front national en fait un parti
dangereux et pas comme les autres la
tournée on est d'accord
le fait que l'employeur se permettent va
décrire aux salariés
ça peut être dangereux si ça bien sûr
d'autres d'autres suggèrent qu est ce qu
on en fait des salariés qui sont
électeurs du front national je travaille
pour cette entreprise est ce qu ils ont
plus peut-être se sentir en tout cas en
contradiction avec leur entreprise
et puis après que c'est une entreprise
voilà qui met en avant sa diversité son
combat contre les discriminations mais
c'est une façade c'est une des
entreprises qui a mis en place contre
l'esprit vk mis en place une charte de
la laïcité
dès 2014 alors que la laïcité c'est un
concept qui vient assurer l'égalité de
traitement des usagers dans la fonction
publique les services publics
donc ça s'applique aux agents qui ont
démissionné dans les entreprises que
chez les espèces entreprises privées
c'est une entreprise où on est en
conflit la cgt pour des problèmes
justement de répression syndicale
vis-à-vis de militaires
donc c'est pas c'est comme ça que ça
devrait être un cas de litige c'est
l'entreprise qui c'est comme ça de
d'encadrer au maximum les explications
dans son sens tout est une question de
l'it après vous avez le conflit
collectif éventuel entre l'expression
des salariés l'expression d'entreprise
qui peut éventuellement se régler à
travers la voix des syndicats
pour ce qui est du conflit individuel
c'est beaucoup plus rare la seule chose
qu'on peut constater éventuellement
c'est à l'occasion d'une expression qui
est libre et
et autorisé son entreprise ne une
discrimination est donc derrière des
sanctions a évidemment pas pas forcément
une sentiment de rupture de contrat il
des sanctions pécuniaires ou des
sections des sanctions termes
d'avancement de probation en voit
d'ailleurs dans le milieu syndical
le fait de deux syndicats souvent votre
carrière ne fonctionnent pas de la même
manière que le salarié qui est
positionné à côté et ça m'en fais le
constat récurrent sur ces questions
politiques ce qui est intéressant en
préparer l'émission j'avais regardé un
petit peu de cas de salariés licenciés
parce qu'ils avaient été candidats sur
des listes front national est
l'employeur avait licencié en lisant
votre candidature les posent difficulté
et vois rien je considère ce une cause
réelle et sérieuse de licenciement
ces licenciements la ont été retoqués
par des cours d'appel qui avait été
saisi les juridictions indiquant même
liberté d'expression liberté publique
fondamentale qui est celle de se
présenter sur un parti autorisé
aujourd'hui et ça ne peut pas être
sanctionnée aucunement rapidement pour
conclure chacun sur cet article 2 de la
dernière loi travail ce n'est pour eux
qui donnent que permet à l'entreprise
c'est pas obligatoire mais d'appliquer
un principe de neutralité ça concerne
les convictions mais aussi l'aspect
religieux rapidement là dessus c'est un
article qu'on estime extrêmement
dangereux pour les libertés syndicales
et les libertés en général des salariés
dans l'entreprise parce que la
neutralité on ne sait pas ce que c'est
que c'est lié au bon fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et que c'est justement
souvent un des sujets on n'a pas du tout
la même vision que que l'employeur et ça
vient vraiment inverser la logique qui
était celle qui a bien expliqué m sont
celles de dire les libertés s'applique
dans l'entreprise et s'il ya abus là on
intervient et là c'est l'inversé par
principe on restreint et après on va
renvoyer du coup on voit plus rien et ça
c'est vraiment très très dangereux pour
les salariés
et on sait que ça c'est une demande des
entreprises et du medef et au travers de
ce combat dans la loi travail il ya
aussi vraiment cet article 2 qui nous
paraît très dangereux merci m telles
sont les conclusions très difficile
d'inverser les règles la liberté c'est
le principe fondamental les restrictions
et doit être examiné vraiment dans le
cadre de dispositifs encadrer par la loi
les dispositions de la loi macron semble
effectivement trop générale et toutes
les difficultés qu'on a dans ces textes
là c'est qu'ils se sont fait à la va
vite pour répondre à une problématique
qui est celle du fait divers comme en
matière pénale quasiment et ici on aime
situation qu'est ce qu'on va faire de
cette règle comment elle sera
interprétée par les juridictions pas
c'est ce qu'on verra si cette règle
demeure applicable
merci merci à tous les deux c'est la fin
de cette émission on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau statut et les
débats très bonne soirée appelée